I saw online that Sarah Huckabee Sanders  called were you in a way laughing  because you're like why isn't Donald  picking up the phone and calling me why  is he having Sarah Huckabee Sanders call  were you upset about it a little way be  honest what you don't know who she was  Sarah [ __ ] yeah did you keep calling  her honey all right honey thank you very  much to have me that's our whole hope  and dream honey thank you you say honey  when Donald's on TV would you have him  say hello to me and maybe like I know  she was about to to my friends head  secretary press secretary I see okay  great great mr. spacely's dollar you  know so no but it was cool that she  called and this press that Donald  expressed the fact that he was very  happy that I'm supporting him and have  his back and supported him you gave a  book to Kim jong-un who was the Trump  book